et avec catherine poujol historienne et
professeur à l'inalco spécialiste de
l'asie centrale
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur rt france est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer ce qui se passe au
kirghizstan ces rivalités politiques qui
créent bien bien des remous dans le pays
actuellement
alors l'expliqué n'est pas forcément
très facile en quelques minutes et je
peux dire c'est que tu était prévisible
c'est à dire que on attendait aux
élections législatives
des mouvements populaires dans la mesure
aussi où le pays était fortement touché
par la crise humanitaire
touchée de produits économiques et
médicales évidemment et donc tout ce qui
se passe est parfaitement prévisible en
plus de du fait qu'il y a eu visiblement
des des problèmes au moment des
élections de falsification des mois dans
un scrutin pourtant organisé
électroniquement avec des passeports
biométriques donc qui laisse peu de
place au doute c'est ce que vous nous
expliquer par ce vote est électronique
cette contestation actuelle ça révèle
une crise économique liée à la crise
sanitaire c'est ce que vous nous
expliquer politiquement également
quelles sont les revendications des des
partisans des deux ceux qui manifestent
aujourd'hui dans la rue alors les jeunes
qui sont sortis les 20 35 ans qui sont
terriblement déçu et de du pouvoir et de
sa gestion de la crise et de sa gestion
économique depuis ces dernières années
et les jeunes clairement ce
pacifiquement demande évidemment la
lustration l'éviction de tous les
fonctionnaires qui étaient là et demande
à renouveau de la classe politique
ce qui est important c'est que il y
avait sept partis d'opposition qui se
sont présentés aux élections et aucun
n'a passé le seuil de 7% pour obtenir un
député et donc du coup
c'est au parlement a vu le renforcement
du parti du pouvoir
il a c'est là où la coupe était pleine
pour la population qui à saint tite
qu'elle se débrouiller tout seul pour
vous avez la compagnie terre et donc est
là elle a chanté une sorte de trahison
la coupe était pleine il fallait sortir
dans l'ain l'armée a été rappelé en
renfort pour ramener l'ordre est ce que
ce cette contestation pourrait dégénérer
alors il est clair que le président dès
le départ a cherché à ne pas envenimer
les choses et appelé la population au
calme et donc n'a pas lancé d'offensive
contre son peuple donc ça fait très
important de le dire et le fait que
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui donc après plusieurs jours
il veut présenter sa démission d'un très
important parce que du côté de la
constitution
l'asnl a la possibilité d'un petit chien
réduite au kirghizstan il fallait que le
président se déclare lui même volontaire
pour ce pour démissionner ou bien
maladie ou bien d'espn et sinon il n'y
avait pas grand chose à faire de ce
point de vue là et donc et donc on peut
pas dire que la la les forces de l'ordre
ont été lancés pour l'instant il faut
espérer que ça reste calme mais ce qui
est plus inquiétant c'est disons le
clivage qui existe politiquement dans ce
pays entre le nord et le sud et les
ressentiments entre les politiciens du
nord et les politiciens du sud qui
serait capable d'agir taylor lautner
fidèles et leurs clans pour pour en
venir directement aux mains c'est ça
qu'il faut absolument à tout prix éviter
alors où là non 'l'annonce voilà delà
d'une sorte de sortie possible avec le
la nomination d'un premier ministre
et là je pense que vous allez me poser
la question oui voilà quelle issue
possible politiquement la nomination
d'un premier ministre bientôt après la
démission du en tout cas et c'est qui
serait effective du président les
services de sécurité aussi aurait un
rôle à jouer dans cette transition pour
les services de sécurité sont entrés
très efficace dans ce pays
reste un instrument important du
maintien de l'ocs donc ils vont
évidemment avoir un rôle
il y a eu un groupe de députés qui s'est
réuni dans un hôtel et qui a voté
l'élection d'un nouveau premier ministre
dont vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
monsieur japarov mais il ne fait pas du
tout l'unanimité c'est à dire que il
il fait l'unanimité de la moitié du
parlement l'autre moitié du parlement
serait totalement contre par contre je
viens de voir passer la noce de l'ancien
candidat à la présidentielle avec baba
s'appelle bec babanov pardon serait le
deuxième candidat au poste de premier
ministre
donc quand vous parlez du fait qu'il ya
déjà un premier ministre il n'est pas il
n'est pas complètement à berrer par la
totalité perçue par la totalité de la
population
donc la situation est donc encore
extrêmement fragile et risquent de
dégénérer
évidemment si rien n'est réglé de ce
point de vue là il faut que le pays
revienne dans avec la légalité par le
biais de l'acceptation par tous d'un
premier ministre qui va former le
nouveau gouvernement et la démission du
président est ce que l à la russie un
rôle à jouer également dans l'apaisement
dans le cadre du traité de sécurité
collective
la russie elle elle elle est très très
intéressé par le maintien de la
stabilité de ce petit pays d'asie
centrale très stratégique au fond de son
espace traditionnel n'influence c'était
un pays où la russie a encore beaucoup
d'influx ans ou la dhimmitude il se rend
chaque année donc bien entendu c'est
très important il ya une base russe à 50
km de bichkek qui est totalement
opérationnel donc
bien évidemment que la russie doit
regarder ce qui se passe avec anxiété et
se demander si cette troisième
révolution va vraiment s'arrêter
rapidement que tout le monde soit en
réalité est ce qu'on peut faire un lien
ce qui se passe en biélorussie par
exemple alors où on peut toujours faire
un lien parce qu'on est dans l'espace
postsoviétique parce que il ya des
racines communes de deux décennies dans
un même dans un même système dans une
même culture
mais bon le cash and co au pouvoir
depuis depuis le début depuis depuis la
fin de l'urss n'a rien à voir avec
l'exception kirghize où on en est au
cinquième président donc le kirghizstan
et le pays est le plus ouvert et le plus
du coup le plus instable politiquement
voilà on peut toujours faire des des
comparaisons mais il faut qu'elles star
est d'une certaine façon assez
rapidement parce que les situations sont
vraiment différents merci beaucoup
catherine poujol d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france